une crise sanitaire à laquelle doit
faire face le corps médical alors
supplémentaires manque de moyens
médecins et spécialistes demandent plus
d'actions de la part du gouvernement
reportage de renault parquet et walid
ben ali au sein d'un cabinet médical
dans le val de marne un cabinet médical
sont morts des fossés laurence dupuy
chirurgie orl s'assure au téléphone de
la gravité des symptômes
je pense qu'il est préférable de
reporter le rendez vous sachant qu'il y
avait pas d'urgence pour l'instant à le
faire exactement restez chez vous comme
ça c'est la situation est complexe à nu
est un rendez vous presque un crève
coeur pour les spécialistes alors que le
coe vie 19 se propage un peu plus fort
chaque jour les annulations lourde de
responsabilités
on a annulé tous les rendez vous qui me
semblait pas urgent pour essayer
d'éviter les contacts en salles
d'attentes qui sont très à risque à mon
sens pour le moment la difficulté se
pose de juger qu'elle est quelles sont
vraiment les urgences puisqu'on ne
connaît pas le délai de
de confinement et d'éviction de contact
des patients donc c'est très difficile
de juger une urgence à deux semaines
trois semaines sans examiner les
patients ça c'est une vraie difficulté
de juger juste par téléphone plus de dix
annulation par jour privilégiez les cas
les plus sérieux dans des conditions de
travail chaque jour de plus en plus
difficile on n'a pas de masque adapté on
a récupéré par fo de solidarité de deux
confrères quelques masques ffp2 pour
continuer un petit peu les consultations
il ya quelques sites dans traite qui
permet de récupérer des masques qui
était utilisé aussi pour le bricolage
mais on commence vraiment être limité on
nous demande nous soignons 2
partir en guerre contre ce virus mais on
n'a pas de moyens pas d'armes c'est
comme aller demander un soldat d'aller
se battre sans armes des masques ffp2
qui couvrent le nez la bouche nécessaire
également pour claire parra chirurgien
orl examinait des oreilles des nez ou
encore des larynx
les risques sont décuplées et les
sentiments sont partagés quant on voit
des patients sans être équipé comme il
faut c'est à dire avec un simple masque
chirurgical pour les examiner faire des
fibroscopie des examens au dos bucco à
des patients qui nous tous dessus
clairement on se dit peut-être qu'en
fait ma responsabilité ce n'est pas de
voir d urgence peut-être que cette
protéger ma famille c'est très difficile
de faire la part des choses entre les
deux mettre à l'abri sa famille
physiquement et économiquement avec près
de 75% de rendez vous en moins les deux
praticiennes ont fait du soin une
priorité nous à l'hôpital ma collègue et
moi on est attaché à l'hôpital dont on
est salarié de l'hôpital ce revenu qu'on
a à l'hôpital il est fixe et il va
continuer ensuite le revenu que nous
avons au cabinet il va largement diminué
mais il ne va pas être égal à zéro donc
on va continuer comme un peu
financièrement avec sa petite lueur
d'espoir venu mercredi des bancs de
l'assemblée nationale le ministre de la
santé a assuré que ces dernières 48
heures 17 millions de masques ont été
livrés à l'ensemble des hôpitaux des
groupement hospitalier de territoire des
ehpad ou encore des organismes de
transport sanitaire